trinidad cette année il maintenant 1.5
million de personnes d'origine chinoise
syrien africains indiens
il ya de tout et de tous voilà les
indiens sont des maîtres depuis toujours
de mélange des peas et assaisonnements
on a en profité à trinidad les indiens
arrivé au 19e siècle dans les caraïbes
ont fortement influencé les cuisines des
antilles anglaises et françaises est née
deviennent ennemis à trinité et tobago
les épices coule dans ses veines
on défend la cuisine antillaise ou la
cuisine de trinidad avec vous oui je me
retrouve à faire un cari exact un carré
d'alou ou un carré de pommes de terre
alors là quand on dit alou parce qu'on
utilise même le mot indy pour la pomme
de terre c'est un certain qaïda loup
c'est parce que les pommes de terre tout
nul en on connaît pas ça
[Musique]
alors là il n'y a rien qu'on mange au
conte cuisine qui a pas été assez sonné
[Musique]
il faut jamais jamais jamais oublié son
qu'humain mais le cumin dont notre
mélange c'est 3 cumin différent dans le
sens que c'est le même qu humain mais le
même cumin nature même cumin terrifié et
le même cumin rôti il faut le curcumin
bien sûr les graines de moutarde le
corian il faut les herbes
il ya quelque chose qu'on appelle enfin
à grandes feuilles etc légèrement
volutes et pillent ya un parfum vraiment
intense et ça s'invente dans presque
tous les plans mais l'âme secret dans sa
les lentilles rôti dont la lentille
l'antique on connaît l'enjeu on vers
laquelle lentilles jaunes
quelles sont les étapes de préparation
d'un carré de pommes de terre comme
facile
[Musique]
on prend les assaisonnements comme le
fameux oignons ail gingembre les herbes
aussi et on met ça dans un matières
grasses dans mon cas c'est toujours lui
le noix de coco on va tous qu'est ce à
un autre mon génie qu'on utilise à
trinidad chiukepo l'argent de sauter on
va sauter tout ça dans la dans la poêle
puis on va ajouter par la suite le lou
le pomme de terre et on va ajouter notre
où on entend quelques minutes que tout
est bien
alors tu enquête choc et shooter
continue à faire tout ce que fera pas à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
dis-moi dis-moi dis-moi c'est bon c'est
vite c'est bon et c'est délicieux
[Musique]
alors la martinique c'est très petit
imaginez soixante dix kilomètres dans sa
plus grande longueur sur à peu près 40
km sa plus grande largeur la culture
africaine a laissé une marque que très
très très importante en martinique
et puis le les arrivants les indiens
d'inde qui ont aussi importer des épices
ont emmené sept couleurs vraiment
particulière à la cuisine la
martiniquaise
le chef jérémie jean baptiste adore le
punch antillais normal pour un
martiniquais
il aime aussi beaucoup le colombo un
mélange des pistes qui lui rappelle son
enfance
la patte de columbo va retrouver du
gingembre frais du cumin frais on veut
retrouver de l'ail frais on va voir les
graines de cumin
les graines de coriandre on va voir les
graines de moutarde et des graines de
fénugrec je vais te montrer et tu vas
pouvoir rendre l'âme
david oui on va broyer tout ça alors
avec mortier comme ça je vais m'amuser
tranquillement et on va continuer à
écraser jusqu'à obtenir une pâte la
fraîcheur des racines vont apporter ce
côté un petit peu pâteux magnifique puis
6 qui va aller agrémenter notre notre
colombo tout à l'heure vous ça ou la fif
a fait a découvert le colombo camp mais
c'est fou ça je pense en même temps que
j'ai découvert mes parents ils ont du
mont mettre un petit peu dans mon lait
de biberons peut-être
[Rires]
alors les étapes la première étape c'est
de faire macérer la viande
donc on m'a sert la viande avec son
assaisonnement la composition de la
marinade va être fait avec du jus de
lime du sel du poivre on va pour
retrouver aussi un petit peu de piment
de l'aïe
on va pouvoir rajouter un petit peu de
persil et on va laisser macérer entre 12
et 24 heures aux intrigues parfait la
deuxième étape revenir les légumes les
découper en base on va retrouver des
oignons
l'épisode du renouveau oignons verts ici
on peut rajouter du coup rejette aussi
si on veut et puis on vient chercher des
jus des petits cubes
comme ça on va retrouver du poivron et
ensuite tout se fait très facilement
très rapidement alors on le déguste avec
du riz donc on va utiliser un riz
parfumé à riz basmati
on va accompagner de comeau avec des
haricots rouges ou des lentilles donc le
riz les haricots et le columbo
[Musique]
alors attends j'ai un petit souvenir
marquant ça va être quand j'ai découvert
l'inspecteur columbo
c'est la série avec le dallage et fait
le lien j'ai dit il ya quelqu'un qui a
piqué le nom d' les pistes de ma maman
[Musique]